I don't want to see this on your MySpace
page myspace was a dated reference even
when this movie came out this penny
holes blown in the HMMWV but nothing
hits Tony an entire article called metal
vs. wood madman wasn't popular enough
yet in 2008 for Roger to play Howard
Stark named actor with a bald head tells
us who the surprise bat guy is four and
a half minutes into the movie forbes
didn't spellcheck this magazine cover or
they liked stupid puns it's a sin either
way Jon Favreau's in Vegas but he's not
picking up beautiful baby so this chick
was so turned on by how brazen Tony
Stark was and asking her to bed that she
got in the car and drove for three plus
hours with him to Malibu does he the
Joker now scene does not contain a lap
dance one at the Paltrow had you taken
negative
how does pepper know that the reporter
took it like a champ was she in the
bedroom with them I bet you a babysitter
and so you know we need to diaper change
thank you let me know and I'll get you a
bottle you're using bottles when you
change diapers you are a terrible
babysitter wait a minute why does the
bad guy insist on having stark build the
Jericho missile instead of just killing
him immediately we learn he's already
got the connection to Obadiah so he can
buy star weapons under the table so why
not just buy a Jericho that way if he
shoots Tony right now he can still get
the Jericho and then fulfill his promise
to Obadiah to kill the guy the arc
reactor is here but then we see it
granted ever so briefly but with that
unmistakable blue glow when he shows
yen's in the blueprints which is before
he's actually put the damn thing in his
chest
that's good Vanya hon the fifty five
times wait a second is the reactor
needed to keep shrapnel out of his heart
or to power the thing if only there was
a shining gleaming clue that could have
tipped the terrorists off the Tony
wasn't building a missile and I would
see them when I leave here Jon Favreau
forgets to show the Grim Reaper behind
the sky to hammer home how doomed he is
where did he get the hair gel someone
forgot to tell this guy he has video
cameras set up in this room the only guy
who actually keeps an eye on the video
feed sees Tony doing some crazy robotic
leg thing and goes in to call them on
there but then just drops it and lets
them get back to work missiles don't
have masks this should have been a dead
giveaway if these guys had ever seen
Hunt for Red October they know to be
careful shooting at a room full of
missiles so none of these guys even got
one bullet anywhere near the giant eye
holes
none of the flames of this explosion get
through his eye holes either our
American cheeseburger well then why the
did you go to Burger King
then it
until such a time well you know that's
just like your opinion man this evil
rich guy gets around on a Segway pepper
Yanks out the magnet Tony tells her not
to take out but then they both just
forget about it and put the new one back
in without a magnet that's pretty funny
but wouldn't serious injury or death
occur from crashing face-first into a
concrete wall and then falling from that
height wait a minute the coffee pepper
brought him back before he talked to
Obie and then tested flight inside and
then tested the flight of the suit
outside is still steaming hot apple and
Dell monitor sharing screen time makes
my geek head spin
apparently secret meetings concerning
Tony's own company that result in
injunctions against him can take place
without his or pepper's knowledge the
shell flies fast iron man never hits
anything or detonates if the bad guys
are making the big hostage video all
just for Obadiah as we learn later in
the film why didn't they just speak
English what language did they use to
communicate with them when setting up
illegal arms deals did it make these
little videos for all their
communication with this paralyzing
technology is perhaps just as good as
anything Iron Man has in his arsenal but
strangely isn't used again really think
just because you have an idea it belongs
to you this is what Stan Lee must have
told Jack Kirby and Steve Ditko back in
the day why doesn't he use this thing to
roll across the floor and save more of
its energy she's fine she's with five
agents they're about to arrest over dad
why doesn't Tony just call her right now
and tell her to stop next time yeah not
for you why the fuck is he hiding
Tony saves innocent civilians in this
car by sending Obadiah flying to crush
innocent civilians in some other car
once you're in a suit this badass do you
really need to punch someone with a
motorcycle
seriously Obadiah just whip out the
keychain gizmo and paralyzes X again
fallen glass is totally harmless when
it's Paltrow's head isn't in a box at
the end of the movie wait a minute the
guy who directed elf did this movie or
is the guy who writes Obama's speeches
either seem qualified but I've been
surprised before this end credits scene
becomes the bane of existence to all
movie theatres ushers everywhere as
people start wading through the end
credits of every single movie before
they leave
hey the bunch of scraps get me major
Allen scramble the Jets now understand
commander that topi does not
self-destruct
you heard it hit the hull and I was
never here